ينضم إلينا الآن كبير المراسلين الطبيين في
CNN الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا سانجاي ،
يخبرنا تغييران رئيسيان على الإرشادات من سمو اليوم ما هي عليه ،
لذا أحدهما كان
نتحدث عنه لبعض الوقت وسمعنا
أن
الإدارة القادمة كانت على الأرجح
متابعة وهذا يعني عدم
كبح هذه الجرعات الثانية بعد الآن ، ضع في
اعتبارك أن لديك جرعتين من
اللقاحين اللذين تم التصريح بهما ، وكانت
الفكرة هي أنك تقوم بتوزيع الجرعة الأولى
وتراجع الجرعة الثانية ،
ما نسمعه الآن هو أن الجرعة
الحالية  لن تكبح الإدارة بعد الآن
تلك الجرعات الثانية
التي أعتقد أنها تعكس ثقة متزايدة
في نوع التصنيع
لسلسلة التوريد هنا
سنرى سنرى كيف يؤدي هذا النوع من
اللعب ، الشيء الثاني هو
توسيع هذه المجموعات ذات الأولوية
التي تتذكرها  في هذا
ما يسمونه المجموعة ، كان
العاملون في الرعاية الصحية والأشخاص الذين كانوا
في مرافق الرعاية طويلة الأجل ،
ما يجدون في كثير من الأماكن هو
أنهم قد يكون لديهم
جرعة  التي لم تكن لتستخدم بخلاف ذلك
أو تعلم أنه لا يمكن
تخصيصها على وجه التحديد لتلك المجموعات الأولى ،
لذا فهم يريدون أن يقولوا بشكل أساسي دعنا
نوسع المجموعات ذات الأولوية حتى لا
نفوت فرصة تلقيح
الأشخاص وسنقوم بذلك  تشمل الأشخاص الذين
تزيد أعمارهم عن 65 عامًا أو البالغين الذين يعانون
من ظروف أخرى موجودة مسبقًا والتي
تراها الآن على الشاشة ،
وهذا النوع يمنحك
انعكاسًا للبلد باللون الأحمر وهي المرحلة الأولى
التي لا تزال العديد من الولايات في تلك
المرحلة المبكرة  من توزيع اللقاح الذي تحركه البعض على
طول ميشيغان هو الأبعد فيما يتعلق
بتلقيح الأشخاص في
المجموعات ذات الأولوية في وقت لاحق
أيضًا ، لذا
قد يساعد هذا في معرفة أنني أعني أنك
تعرف أن
هناك الكثير من المشكلات المتعلقة
بإخراج هذه اللقاحات  نظرًا لأننا نتعلم
أن أكبر واحد ربما يكون مجرد
القوة البشرية
لتلقيح الأشخاص فعليًا ، لاحظ
الأشخاص بعد تلقيحهم ،
تأكد من أن لديك لقطات مربعة
لملاحظتهم فقط الأساسيات مثل
الذي - التي